here's a weak first men Adam Levine I'm
taking the mic baby I don't thing we get
nervous anymore really we do it so often
it's kind of just you know like taking
off our shoes help us out you're going
in for a kiss
want to take you back for a second mm
for taking me back it's been a really
charmed year and we're very fortunate to
have experienced it we're we're big in
2004 I guess right would you tell that
guy now what would I tell that guy now
you have no idea
just wait that year ain't so true now
did you know Adam actually meant his
future maroon 5 band mates in high
school and what we found out in all our
vintage et interviews Adams always been
smooth with the ladies what are you
doing for Valentine's Day my every woman
in America flowers you are just as cute
as I thought you would be you have every
girl in Hollywood after hi everybody
from Mandy Moore to Madonna
I actually am dating
[Music]
of course the most important ladies in
Adams life now are his wife Behati and
their two daughters and let's not forget
his mama
Patsy interviewed Adam for et back in
2012 did you ever think when you started
the band at 9th grade at Brundtland
school that you'd be here I did look in
a lot it's my boy but you but you know
that and not having a plan B might have
been part of that too like I just like
listen I have a plan B plan a is not
gonna work well I love you very much
that's the best interview ever
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]